stop color grading this is how you get
the classic negative film simulation on
your Sony camera so I just started
playing with the fx6 which has a more
complex picture profile menu than most
Sony mirrorless cameras and you can
actually shift colors to saturate or
saturate each color channel so it's just
like color creating inside the camera
you can get Fuji's classic negative look
without any color grading so let me show
you the settings long press the menu
button go to the paint look and hit OK
enter the base look and you want to
select still for a Punchy look go back
one page
next I raise the Black Point to give my
image to film my contrast and the
following settings are for green till
Hue and the Shadows
here are my detail settings and these
will give your image the softest detail
possible straight out of the camera
next we have the Matrix and here's where
you actually shift colors so here are my
settings for the classic negative test
it out and let us know in the comments
if you like it more recipes on my
website